alors à 30 secondes pour imiter des
chanteuses de r'n'b je sais que tu fais
à la perfection rayhana qu'à moi
à
[Applaudissements]
tha
[Musique]
il a changé tout
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si tu journal numéro de malika ménard
kenny qui est très belle mais n'en est
pas un couple est alors à l'eau alors
malika oui ouais c'est avec boudali ça
va ça va je te dérange mais qu'est ce
que j'ai vu c'est juste parce qu'en fait
si je vais faire mon avant-première et
du coup je voulais savoir si tu voulais
venir
l'homme en fait je préfère être honnête
avec toi comment y circulent dans les
murs et effectuer les dragues un peu
c'est que pendant longtemps avec ok
bonne soirée
enfin je sais pas mais en plus le
paradoxe avec un battant frère c'est pas
possible
le motard est glamour il n'était pas
bien
il ya quelqu'un qui a complètement
changé oui il ya quelqu'un alors c'est
notre invité mystère vous avez remarquez
bien sûr que c'était kelly vdev 10,1 à
la voix voilà voilà même de dos on l'a
reconnu et c'est vrai qu'elle a décidé
de changer de style
elle a décidé si tu un nouveau style à
nouveau look pour une nouvelle vie
magnifique vraiment kelly vely retournez
vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est un changement de look away jeu
justement je rejoins ce qu'elle dit et
mamika dans le sens où moi je me sentais
vraiment pas bien dans ma peau et
j'avais envie de me retrouver
et là vous êtes retrouvé ma fais moi
benjamin girbal annoncé une seule chose
aujourd'hui une seule apparemment le mas
nous protège alors dehors dedans mettez
votre masse quand vous bougez en fait ça
fait bouger vos seins dans la famille
donc qu'est ce que ça veut dire
on va voir si les langues de bois parce
que vous êtes facho qui se faisaient
peur de la choqué parce qu'il ya un
règlement
sa belle soeur alors alors pas du tout
je peux pas l'avoir mais que ce soit
bien clair
non mais je peux pas mais je le dis
d'accord ces sabres et maintenant
laissez pas votre femme
c'est la soeur de sa femme qui est
divine comparé à l jeune médian belge et
le j'ai le droit de dire que ma femme
est beaucoup plus belle que ça ça je
crois que c'est dans le coeur d'accord
allez allez presse sylvie aussi c'est la
guerre dans les parages non mais on sait
que jean marc carnicé tu nous regardes
bonjour marques et le talent est
jean-marc je me prends ça pour une
guitare il avait quelque chose c'est de
votre faute la buav août cyril mais au
moins c'est pas parce que tu as dit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et aussi à votre box
oui personnellement je suis beaucoup
plus choqué par le fait que jamais
maître pas dessous de 5 ans je vous
explique c'est que chaque soir on mettra
quelqu'un de la rédaction en tout cas la
glace ce soir on a quelqu'un qui est
avec nous c'est jeanne mizrahi
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire je vais vous présenter à
nos invités également et ils sont là ça
fait longtemps que les attend
youssef hajdi et jonathan carré et je
sais que tu es un des meilleurs danseurs
prenez j'aimerais que vous regardez
vraiment youssef c'est que vous fassiez
exactement la même chose un peu plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c
à
[Applaudissements]
j'ai donc vous lancer sur des anecdotes
et vont en bon mito je vous laisse vous
en dire plus c'est ce que j'ai eu c'est
fake moi en voiture à youcef saïbi pas
me donner passionata bis rue que le
cerveau y avait de l'eau dedans marc o
vous aperçu avec kim kardashian super u
de guingamp c'est quoi cette histoire
avec kim kae relâche écoute
kim kardashian moi ça fait longtemps
face ça fait longtemps que je bosse pour
elle tu as gens enfin page en secret
mais où je suis je suis je m'occupe de
résoudre des enquêtes et tu sais qu'elle
s'est fait quand même tapé ses bijoux
moi je sais alors c'est une vraie
histoire café du un vrai boom dans le
métier est fait dans l'histoire
j'étais pas dans l'histoire mais j'ai
des muscs et les gardiens qui
travaillait au super u donc on a fait
tous les super u de france garniture
ayant on l'a trouvé et le cas où ils
travaillent et aux légumes
sinon
un débat est tous super u lugano le
galway et c'est un braqueur vendeur de
légumes non ce qui arrive de plus en
plus souvent mais c'est sûr et ça c'est
vrai que ça devient monnaie courante
monnaies courantes en aval très souvent
on me l'a dit quelque chose qui revient
beaucoup à dont je lui ai demandé des
explications ce soir au la casta est
infâme casta fait le caïd dans les loges
mais devant cyril bizarrement ce qu'un
vrai bouffon il paraît que fait le
cailly dans les loges est anormal quand
vous n'êtes pas là je prends je prends
une place mais j'aimerais bien savoir
qui a glissé à votre avis qui est beau
c'est un long mais ça c'est les jambes
c'est sûr c'est valérie b derrière
valérie racontez nous évidemment je
cogne on se connaît parfaitement bien et
donc vous savez quand vous n'êtes pas là
oui c'est en fait il se prend pour un
patron mais c'est pas trop ma maman et
perse puis nous fait chier
et puis voilà et quand ils vous arrivent
et c'est mon souhait
[Applaudissements]
chéri ce soir c'est un grand événement
dans tpm parce que nous recevons la
personnalité de l'année le professeur
didier raoult y sommes pris d'un rooney
je vous l'avais déjà rencontré le
professeur mais jamais à marseille
j'aime je crois que vous avez créé un
petit truc bas il y avait un mémoire
[Rires]
alors non parce que je vous le dis les
règles ont été claires
ils veulent juste voulu poser des
questions sur voilà sur son personnage
et ses tirs a fait mercredi
faites votre truc et il va rentrer après
qui sera non non non non non je ne le
fais pas tu me le faire c'est lui qui
débute à la pantsula qui voit en lui
je veux faire rayon des conneries après
tu vas peur la peur des coups et belges
et les cours et les couilles 4-1
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
lui qui minent photo la topolino et nous
emmerdent céline chef
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vivez nature été recoupées époux ils
fêtaient le commandant koné ferrand où
tu vois jamais reprise coordonnée
je crois pas que l'on reconnaît type a
est ce que vous voulez la surprise du
premier défaut n'est pas légal
[Applaudissements]
oh
cet après midi j'en pleure nom seidnaly
piqué qui balaie pas débutée mercier
michel mado c'est le sosie officiel de
google